[Musique]
un soir d'hiver dans le 12e
arrondissement parisien une météo à ne
pas mettre un militant dehors pourtant
ici devant le palais omnisports de paris
bercy une cinquantaine de personnes
s'est réunie pour lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes parmi elles
souder une jeune iranienne de 30 ans est
venue accompagnée de quelques amis
donc on a fait des trucs on va mettre
comble son but qui en peine en appel
pour les femmes des femmes sont dits
soude est arrivé en france il ya huit
ans pour poursuivre ses études mais
aussi pour fuir un ex compagnon violent
elle a laissé derrière elle sa famille y
a un passé de femme battue une situation
tristement ordinaire en iran un pays où
la condition des femmes a encore
beaucoup de progrès à faire
depuis 2003 soudé milite pour la
campagne internationale d'un million de
signatures un mouvement féministe
iranien qui se bat pour changer le
statut des femmes au pays
depuis quelques mois la communauté
internationale se mobilise pour sakineh
devenue le symbole de la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes en iran
dans sa prison de tabriz cette iranienne
de 43 ans attend la mort depuis cinq ans
après avoir été condamnée à la
lapidation pour adultère
et même face à cette pratique barbare la
femme n'est pas l'égal de l'homme cedh
mais d'autres applications les femmes et
les hommes ne sent pas lapidée de la
même manière
dire lawn est enterré jusqu'à la taille
et la femme jusqu'au poitrine donc
un homme ou une femme qui arrivent à se
sortir du trou il est enterré il faut se
sauver mais voilà quand on est enterrée
jusqu'à la poitrine on n'a pas les mêmes
choses que quand on est enterré jusqu'à
la taille
autre exemple significatif devant la
justice iranienne un homme vaut deux
femmes du coup soudé organise la lutte
depuis paris une démarche inconcevable à
téhéran
[Musique]
c'est quelqu'un qui m'appellent
capa d'ammoniac
c'est un pari
[Musique]
deux jours plus tard c'est dans le 14e
arrondissement qu'on retrouve sous dès
ce soir elle est venue avec une petite
partie des quinze mille iranien de
france accueillir une compatriote
célèbre écrivain féministe exil en
allemagne dans la salle de nombreux
intellectuels
personnalités publiques un monde sort
chaude jaillit est une des grandes
figures du féminisme iranien ce soir
elle présente son dernier recueil genre
de best of de ses articles sur la
condition des femmes au sein de la
république islamique
le premier
ministre
aujourd'hui en iran une activiste
féministe est considéré comme un
opposant au régime un délit passible de
prison et deux coups de fouet
comme chaque mercredi soudé vient donner
un coup de main à l'association céda une
quinzaine de réfugiés iraniens viennent
y chercher de l'aide pour remplir leur
demande d'asile de logement et de
transport
ici fugier trouve une oreille attentive
au drame qu'elles ont pu vivre dans leur
pays ben là on est en train de préparer
des petites plateau
des fruits en fait parce que les fruits
c'est vraiment la dernière chose qu'un
réfugié peut avoir accès à manger on va
apprendre
bahreïn a fui l'iran il ya quelques mois
l'année dernière cette étudiante a
activement pris part aux manifestations
du mouvement vert à l'époque des
millions d'iraniens descendent dans la
rue pour s'opposer au régime de mahmoud
ahmadinedjad
je viens de
a plaisanté
non
[Musique]
l'ami de barran elle n'a malheureusement
pas pu quitter le pays pourtant elle y a
enduré un véritable calvaire
mon ami qui se fait violer par son petit
copain et il a porté plainte
auprès de gouvernements disons de
justice et finalement c'est la fille qui
avait condamné un coup de fouet pour
avoir eu des relations illégales
ce soir souhaiter un rendez-vous dans
les bureaux du quotidien le monde son
ami chahla chafiq grande militante
féministe interdite de séjour en iran
doit recevoir le prix de la recherche
universitaire une récompense perçue par
la communauté comme une victoire contre
le régime islamiste
port du voile obligatoire polygamie
l'iran est un pays où les droits des
femmes sont souvent bafoués et pourtant
dans le système iranien plusieurs femmes
sont élues au parlement un vrai paradoxe
il faut pas oublier qu'il y avait une
comme député qui a proposé il ya
quelques années de reprendre les
prostituées pour finir avec la
prostitution il ne doit pas penser que
tout les femmes sont toutes les femmes
sont des opposants et ahmadinejad
utilise utilise
depuis la révolution islamique d'iran il
ya 31 ans la répression envers les
femmes ne cesse de s'accroître mais en
2010 plus de 60 % des étudiants sont des
femmes les opposants d'aujourd'hui et de
demain